David what was your first job in the
entertainment business my first job in
entertainment was a street magician in
New York City I I knew I wanted to be in
show business and I wasn't sure how to
get into it and I saw somebody else
doing it and I thought well this looks
easy
so we do a magic store and I bought a
trick and I created a character and I
did a comedy magic I did a comedic
version of a magic trick and I just
stood on the street had a hat and it was
great training for somebody wants to go
into the comedy business because if I
wasn't good people just walk away
immediate feedback no waiting for
thumbs-up or thumbs-down or YouTube
comments you knew right away and it was
really really good training and I did
that for a couple of years and from
there I went into stand-up comedy I got
off the street and dropped the magic
okay was this your card yeah I dropped
the magic when it started doing comedy
clubs and went from there my second job
was stand-up comedian I toured like 200
colleges doing a one-man show and that
was also really good training because
they were all over the place and so it's
a great way to develop timing and jokes
and when a joke would bomb what would
you do how would you get out of it oh I
didn't ever try to say that with a
straight face well you would have me
most of the college audiences were great
so that wasn't a problem but we did
comedy clubs you never know what kind of
but you would have a joke ready to talk
about if it bomb if you just acknowledge
it and then the audience in you
acknowledge the reality of it then the
audience laughs it breaks the tension
now this is assuming that the joke
before the joke after doesn't bomb if
you're bombing a hundred percent I don't
I don't actually don't know what that's
like that's not bragging but that would
be we've all seen that and that's not
just that's just terrible
so you would you would acknowledge when
something wasn't working and then almost
make fun of it and then move on and that
was how you dealt with it yeah I
actually wrote a routine about where I
told a joke that I knew most of the
audience wouldn't like so that I could
follow up with
four or five jokes about the joke it
sounds kind of meta and it was but I
would tell it here I'll tell you the
joke okay here's the joke that most of
you won't like okay it's a knock-knock
joke I'm gonna do all the parts I was at
all the knock-knock joke parts okay just
why knock-knock what's that that no one
sighs of course security and we drunk at
a comedy club I'm sorry I will do all
the part okay thank you yeah easy for
you okay okay here we go here's the joke
I'm gonna do all the parts of the
knock-knock joke
knock-knock the time traveller who's
there knock-knock the time traveller
who's there at this point about 1/3 of
the audience would get it and the other
2/3 the eyes would turn to them and ask
to be explained you get it don't lie
people don't get it don't feel bad if
you don't well the time travelers moved
on to another realm no oh okay
I'm traveller travelled forward in time
uh-huh to say who was there before you
asked who's there oh okay he traveled it
knock-knock the time traveller who's
there
he moved forward in the joke right the
time traveller moved forward in time to
the joke I think is it and about 1/3 of
people in the audience loved that joke
okay and the other four are like you
they're like you know either don't think
it's funny
or they don't you know it's not their
thing but like certain types of ideas
love it like I did it it I did it
Caltech they carried me off on their
shoulders Oh nerds love that you know
it's like yeah I got they named a dorm
after me I mean it was not really but
that would be nice and so then I did a
series of jokes about that joke and
about why am i doing a joke that I know
people won't like so it was an entree
into my personality of someone being
having a unique point of view and daring
just you know to start their act that
way so but that's like meta
comedy it's not observational Seinfeld
type things like that but I learned a
long time ago - when you're quirky
because people who really like that joke
like it's like people like certain TV
shows or certain characters and they
really love them because it speaks to
them and other people like how can you
like that show everything they get
passionate about but the people who
really love it really love it shows like
30 rock for example was never huge in
the ratings you know it was like 90s and
stuff in the ratings it's never big but
the people who liked it but me included
a really loved 30 rock and it stayed on
the air because the demographic who
watched it was an affluent Democratic
demographic it had a huge audience of
people who made more than $100,000 a
year so they kept it on the air and ran
commercials for those people so that's
the great thing about the business today
is if you're making a quirky stupid try
and travel knock-knock joke there's
gonna be enough of an audience who will
like that kind of thing because it fits
you you know it's like when you meet
someone in a bitter dating and you meet
somebody who gets your jokes
it's answer you're like yes right they
get me right yes so then from New York
City when did you come to Los Angeles
okay now it's like the 90s in the 90s
and what was your first entertainment
job in the 90s well AOL circa I dial-up
I did some acting I did commercials the
stand-up comedy I was on Star Search I
did that whole thing you know during
that and then I got into writing mm-hmm
but I did some acting for a while and
that was fun I was on the series working
girl from the movie with Sandra Bullock
and that was before she was Sandra
Bullock you know was one of the people
well a lot of people worked on that show
but things like that and then I got into
writing when someone asked me some head
she was doing a murder mystery dinner
theater she wanted to make a business of
doing those was a good idea but she
wasn't a writer and she said you're
funny would you write this script and
she told me
what the mystery was she says okay this
person is gonna be guilty and they did
it this and then that and right around
bad so I thought hmm
and I wrote a script and I put in some
quirky things that I thought no one
would get but me or no one would like
but me like for example the detective
who comes in have you been to one of
these murder mystery thing I have yeah
II have these characters come it's a
techno coming like a 1940's detective
with a fedora and he came in and he's a
you know case in the room and doing his
thing and I wanted to do a voiceover
like they doing all the film noir where
like the lead detective the hard-bitten
guy there's a voiceover I wanted to do a
live voiceover so I came over the device
where he would do his own voice over his
own narration and he would the device I
came up with as he was put his hands on
his chin and look up like that and then
he would say I walked into the room and
she had legs up to her or whatever and
and he did I thought that'll never work
and it completely worked the actor loved
doing it the audience got it immediately
and that was a really good lesson for me
is that when you celebrate your own
quirkiness you're only unique point of
view it will frequently resonate with
the audience like in things like for
example Napoleon Dynamite is non-stop
quirkiness all the way through how many
of us are that guy no one he's a unique
character but there's little pieces of
them that we celebrate and we recognize
it as it was like oh if I had a llama
I'd go feed him lasagna too and if you
remember that scene but just call he's
look any he's an underdog and people
identify it celebrates quirkiness so I
put things like that into my first
script they rehearsed it they put it on
the audience liked it and I had two
reactions I'm like wow this is amazing
it's when you're a writer and you see
your work being done for the first time
by good actors and a good production and
it works it's a huge it's a high I mean
it's just an amazing feeling because
you've been watching entertainment your
whole life and now you just made it and
it's a it's an amazing feeling I had two
reactions that one which got me hooked
they're doing and the second reaction
which this is easy
which sadly was not true because as you
know it's not easy to make a career of
it but it was enough that I kept doing
it she had to television writing credits
one was Sybil what was the other one
Caroline in the city okay great Lea
Thompson mom from Back to the Future
mm-hmm so how did you land those two
jobs that's really interesting
well I knew Bob Meyer was the exec
producer on Sybil that was my first job
and he's great it's very very nice guy
and he let me come in and pitch him I
wanted to sell script he let me come in
and pitch him ideas and then maybe liked
one he made me to write it and I at the
time I was I had the job I had on the
show was audience warm up I got a feel
familiar yeah but anytime you go to see
alive he said you go see a live show a
live show takes anywhere from three four
five six hours I worked on friends
friends took eight hours to shoot every
shows different and they have a comedian
who talks to the audience in between and
I was doing all these shows on the road
hundreds of shows on the road I wanted
to get off the road and I found this gig
and it's great because you can stay in
LA and work and so I was working on
Sybil and so I came in and pitched about
my er ideas for scripts for episodes so
I'm coming to pitch him something I
thought was hysterical and he go well
David that's very funny but that's not
our show and I not such a nice man he
let me pitch and get it again
I kept pitching funny ideas but they
just weren't that show so I'm thinking
okay this is the show starring simple
shepherd it's a really good show
Christine Baranski co-starred won an
Emmy funny show about a middle-aged
woman who's a single mom with teenage
daughter and best friend and what do I
have in common you know with a
middle-aged menopausal woman they did
stories on that so I said what I'm
common and it's a challenge as a writer
to come up with that and I thought so
finally came and I pitched I go okay
civil wakes up one morning something is
giving her grief her ex-husband her
daughter so I was a problem she goes to
eat some chocolate because that's the
comfort food and finds out she's
developed an allergy to chocolate a bob
goes there you go so I found something
in common
I found something in common with a
middle-aged woman just we love chocolate
and I found that and that was a game
that was a big lesson to me it you know
how to find a key in to whatever show
you're working for to find something you
have in common so you can write it with
authority and so it feels real and why
not continue with the acting there was
something in it obviously that kept you
well I got I just loved the writing so
much you know I did mention commercials
you have to go in like a 50 auditions to
get one commercial and it was fun and I
liked it but I really liked the writing
and then I started directing and that
was that was when I was really really
hooked because it's just making that all
come to life and working with actors
it's if there's something magical about
it I need to sound I mean to sound sappy
everything but there really is something
amazing about it because when things are
done well it touches me when I watch a
movie that works it just really touches
me there's nothing like it
and so being a part of that process and
creating it once you start creating it
and you start to get successful it's
actually pretty humbling because you're
really grateful that things work it's
like Shakespeare in Love
Shakespeare in Love the moneylender
wants his money back from the guy whose
theatre it is and he and the guy who
sees he says this is all falling apart
he goes no no it's all going to work out
it showbusiness seems like the road to
imitate disaster but it always turns out
well in the end and he goes how he goes
no one knows it's a mystery I mean that
line was so brilliant because it's true
there are thousands of people in this
town all around us right now and these
zip codes working really hard to make
good movies and good TV shows and when
it works there's no better feeling so
was there some sense of relief or a
feeling of transition in that you know
you said you didn't want to be on the
road anymore and so now all that
pressure of being the front man was off
you and now you
me behind the scenes there was that part
of it too that that's very it's very
gratifying in a different way being
front of audiences doing stand-up comedy
there's it's very gratifying to get a
laugh you know so much you've got an
audience of thousands it looks like a
physical wave of sound that hits you and
that's that's fun it really I mean it's
it's a great feeling but being behind
the seas in creating something is
something tangible it's gonna last
something that somebody's gonna put in
their DVD player in ten years or stream
online in ten years or put their virtual
reality glasses on whatever whatever the
next thing is there's just something
really satisfying about that because I
love it as an audience member and you
know I love it as a so when you creates
it David all these years of being in
entertainment whether it's a magician a
comic writer why now with your latest
project which is all be next door for
Christmas how long did it take you to
think of it to actually get it on paper
to then want to cast for it well I was
raising I want to make an interpretive
film that I could direct and I was
raising money for another movie that's
much more expensive like a four or five
million dollar movie and I was just
going through all the processes of
talking to rich people going to it but a
film company is doing all the things you
have to do to raise that kind of money
and it was really difficult so I thought
you know I better try to be smart about
this I'm gonna write a low-budget movie
so that I can raise the money more
easily and make this movie and then
after that we'll do the bigger one so I
specifically came up with this Christmas
movie for business reasons and artistic
reasons the artistic reasons are LM
Christmas movies I mean they're really
fun they're all about Christmas being in
jeopardy and a family driving each other
crazy but they come through stronger in
the end they're just really fun to watch
and the good ones get a little really
get sentimental at the end but they get
there in a way that they earned it
you know and so I enjoy that and the
second reason we're business reasons
Christmas movies Sal
okay there's a million of them on cable
they always sell there's a big demand
for them and the studio's don't make
them they make very few of them let me
go in every couple of years or so and so
they're in the business of making the
student the major studios make sequels
prequels prequels to the sequels and you
have comic books movies and things like
that that's their business they'll make
150 million dollar movie spend $200
marketing it and make 800 million
dollars on it and that's it's a great
business model but the independent
producers are filling in the vacuum of
the small character driven movies the
comedies and family Christmas comedies
just aren't made that often especially
witty ones and so I thought for business
purposes this this is gonna sell and
because it's a Christmas movie it's
gonna sell year after year after year a
Christmas story was made in 1983 and it
still makes a ton of money every season
because people buy it and give it as a
DVD people stream it you get it on cable
it's it holds up Christmas movies if
you'll forgive the pun Christmas movies
are evergreen they're forever people
still watch It's a Wonderful Life from
70 years ago and still has an income
stream for the studio so that's one of
the reasons I decide to make a Christmas
movie is people provide income for the
producers and the investors for decades
to come
that's the idea so that was one of the
business reasons and also I wanted to do
a low budget and so I wrote the movie
specifically that way if you want to
write a low-budget movie write for what
you've got or what you can get cheaply
don't write big explosions that you know
there's no there's no there's no digital
effects in our movie nothing like that
no expensive post-production it's a
character-driven comedy okay and the
plot of the movie is sixteen-year-old
girl her parents have ruined her life
with Christmas their Christmas crazy
drives her nuts she's got a boyfriend
the first love of her life he's coming
to visit her at Christmas she doesn't
want to subject him to a crazy family so
she does what any teenager would do is
she hires two actors to play her parents
and has a fake Christmas dinner for her
boyfriend of the empty house next door
who among us has not done that anyway
what could go wrong right so most of the
movie takes place at two houses right
next door to each other so we can set up
the crew we can set up the location and
we don't have to move for four weeks now
I'm sure a lot of your audience knows
that when you're making a film the less
you have to travel you know the more
money you can save the more time you
save so I set it up that way to be
contained you know there's a couple of
scenes outside there but most of it
takes place right there at those houses
right next door to each other also when
you write it have two characters in most
of the scenes if you have three four
five six seven characters every
character in that scene that's another
character you've got a cover you've got
to get footage of that character every
time you do that takes more time so have
a lot of scenes with just two characters
if you have kids and pets in the movie
and ours is a Christmas movie so there
are you know there's some kids and a cat
named parsley and they're only in the
cat's only in two scenes and it doesn't
do any tricks people just start carrying
it that's it okay and the kids the
little kids are only in about 6 or 7
scenes so that's another way save money
if you have stuff that's gonna take time
to do
don't write a lot of scenes for it ok so
there are a lot of tricks and things you
can do to write a low-budget movie so
that you can shoot it well because if
you're writing above your budget level
then you're gonna be making so many
compromises left and right that the
movie is just gonna suffer I mean you
know that's there's only so many hours
in the day to shoot you know actors can
only work so each day and the other
thing is if you write a good character
driven comedy or any kind of characters
in one piece you attract better actors
because you're giving them something
good and they can sink their teeth into
that they want to do so those are all
the elements artistic elements that I
wrote specifically into the movie that
were driven by business decisions and
you have Jennifer Tilly attached we have
Jennifer Tilly yes I'm very excited
about that
she's a oscar-nominated for Broadway for
arms are four bullets over Broadway with
Woody Allen and she
tells great Woody Allen stories very
funny stories while working with him and
yes she's got a Chucky movie coming out
right now there's these fun Chucky
movies she also a poker champion she's
won several poker championships yes yes
I played poker with her she's really
good basically it's a poker lesson
playing with her but yeah Jennifer
Tilly's attached to play the woman who
owns the house next door that the kids
staged the fake Christmas dinner in so
she's great to work with she's a she's a
such good comedic timing always makes
the joke work always makes the script
better than it actually is and we love
actors they do that make us look like
geniuses Thank You Jennifer so how did
you get the script tour I was working on
a TV show and I came up with her and she
was in the cast and I came up to her
after at a wrap party and said said hi
and said can I give you a script for a
movie that I'm doing and I don't mean to
be obnoxious and I you know sure you get
this all the time
I was saying it like half apologetically
and she stalked me and she goes sure and
sure give it to me she was very sweet
and thankfully she liked the script and
that's yeah I just I just walked up to
her and wasn't creepy tip somehow it's
but yeah it's a nice guy yeah I mean
after remember two actors need material
they need projects they need to do
things too so if you approach them in a
respectful businesslike way then you
know if you act like you have something
they might want then maybe they'll take
a look at it I've had good success with
that actually just saying hi now I know
you are raising money for the film on an
equity crowdfunding site and and you've
briefed us a little bit behind the
scenes that there are certain things you
can't talk about and forgive me if I
overstep the bounds so me at any moment
if it's something because I'm used to
interviewing people that have been on
you know Kickstarter IndieGoGo some of
these other sites so what is equity
crowdfunding first
most what is it how is it different from
Kickstarter and IndieGoGo well it's a
new law that's just come into effect
it's only been around for a year it went
into effect in 2016 and it's called
regulation crowdfunding or equity
crowdfunding investment crowdfunding yes
sir and before this law came into effect
if you wanted to invest in a start-up
like Facebook or something like that
when they were first starting up legally
you had to be what they call a high net
worth individual you had to be somebody
I believe that you make over $200,000 a
year or however our million dollars in
net worth and that let out that that
left out 90% of the population 90% of
population could not invest in these
only these venture capitalists in these
really wealthy people could do it but
this new law came into effect that
allows other businesses to raise money
to everyone we can the average person
can invest is something with equity
crowdfunding and you couldn't do that
before and the difference between this
and Kickstarter is when you put money
into an equity crowdfunding project like
ours Madonn Kickstarter they give you a
DVD or a t-shirt or something like that
this you get a piece of the company if
the movie makes money you make money so
you enjoy the success or failure of the
movie fails of course movies can always
see crash and burn anything can crash
and burn but if it succeeds you go along
for the ride so that's the big
difference a lot of companies are doing
it a lot of microbreweries restaurants
coffee companies they've all
successfully raised millions of dollars
electric cars there's a new electric car
out there there's a guy who's
successfully raised millions of dollars
for a jetpack
the first non-military jetpack yeah it's
so cool and I mean they have the video
it's real it works and you and you can
put money into that company and things
like that there's tampon of the Month
Club
oh there's I mean everything you could
possibly imagine there's somebody
starting up a company
under this new law we are the first
feature-length narrative film to raise
money this way in the United States
they've been a couple in Europe you know
a couple in Asia but we're the first
ones in America to do this with a
feature-length film one other company
did a collection of short films but
we're the first ones to do a full-length
narrative film and it's really exciting
it's cool because it's new and nobody's
done it so it's really exciting and
we're succeeding it's going well it is I
don't know if you're allowed I forgive
me if I'm overstepping my bounds we can
cut this out but are you a lie if I say
the dollar amount I mean you've done
very well since April of 2017 is when
you launch the campaign right yes we're
doing well the SEC the security team is
changed which regulates this offering
it's not like Kickstarter or anybody can
just do it there's a lot more involved
in us making this offering and they have
rules about we can talk about okay we
can't actually talk about dollar amounts
people have to go to the website and all
the information is right there it's
super easy to read and all that's right
there
but I can tell you this for a year
previously before we did the equity
crowdfunding campaign I went around and
talked to rich people people outside the
business who who were wealthy and I
tried to talk to him to raise money and
I raised a little money to go here in
seven weeks I have raised a hundred and
forty percent of what I raised in a year
talking to rich people so I love equity
crowdfunding because instead of having
to convince a few individuals with money
to write a check you can talk to the
whole world international investors we
have investors from Australia and Europe
who are putting money and anyone can
invest in this anyone and it's really
exciting because we just have to get
their message out to the crowd and
people who get it people who get the
movie that we're doing who understand it
are like oh this is fun it's an
investment - cool so instead of let me
tell you story about one investor I
talked to I was talking that's very
wealthy fellow nice guy we're sitting in
we
back chairs next to his private lake
okay I felt like I was in the movie
Casablanca with Sidney Gracie and I'm
pitching him project and he says well
you know this lead character he read the
script and he's not in the business so
he he's not used to read his script he's
just reading you know of flowcharts and
accounting statements and the profit and
loss sheets but he read this script and
he says you know in the beginning of
this movie I don't like the lead
character she's not very likable I said
well yeah but you like her later he goes
yeah yeah I like her by the end I go
well that's the idea is that she changes
movies have an arc where the character
starts had a certain way they go through
the story and if it's an upbeat ending
if it's a comedy than they improve their
life they if they find love they find
success whatever they find it and we go
along in the journey so she changes and
he goes
mm-hmm-hmm but I don't like her in the
beginning I said oh oh right and I
explained it again what an arc was and
I'm sure a lot of your the people who
are your readers who go to your site
there were a lot of my writers they
understand this in a movie you change
there's an arc so we talked for 20
minutes like this and he kept saying but
but I don't like her in the beginning
and finally I said to the guy I said you
know there was a character in a movie
she was very mean she used people she
didn't care about anybody but herself
she was selfish she was basically just a
horrible and she this character
was the lead character and the
highest-grossing film of all time called
Gone with the Wind and and this guy was
in his 70s so he knew that movie got
that and he goes he goes oh oh and it
was just surreal have you this
conversation with this guy here trying
to explain this to him and it wasn't his
business so he didn't understand it cuz
he didn't get this business whereas when
we do the crowdfunding the equity
crowdfunding a lot of people even if
it's not their business they get it
they've thought about it you know they
thought oh
that would be fun and so they get it and
it's such a tremendous release we get it
on our Facebook page we have a Facebook
page for the movie for that Christmas
movie on Facebook and it's so we had
last weekend we make a little post about
the movie and who's in it and stuff like
that and we had a sweet little grandma
from Missouri she she posted this is
great the thumbs up and it was so
heartwarming to see that we've reached
some sweet lady you know that we didn't
know in the middle of nowhere and she
gets us and as filmmakers and writers
that's there's nothing better than when
people get what you're doing David are
you able to talk about how many people
you knew personally or is that is that
off limits I could know about that and
and how many investors do you have by
the way we have about a we have about a
hundred and forty investors at this
point around there and we only
personally know about five or six of
them Wow
we started the campaign and we just went
on social media and spread the word as
much as we possibly could around so
these are people from all over the
country and people that we don't know
who get what we're doing and they want
to see a fun Christmas movie get made
they want to see it and they understand
since they like Christmas movies they
figure hey and let them other people
must like them too so this is probably a
good business decision as well that's
what they're telling us anyway and we
just we take it really seriously the
responsibility to do our best for this
movie so that we justify these people's
faith in us you know it's a really
serious thing well slightly switching
gears off-camera you told me about sag
and some of the rules regarding casting
actors and some of the perks or things
like that can we talk about that a
little bit in terms of parts and things
like that sure absolutely
I've seen other Kickstarter campaigns
for movies and sometimes one of the
perks they get
is if you put X amount of dollars in
they'll give you a part in the movie
which I think it's great that's like a
fun way for somebody who looks seriously
wants to break into the business to get
on the set some successful people you
know and that's a good thing where
people just do it for a lark just all
it'd be fun you know and I thought that
was great
but then as we're putting this together
because it's equity crowdfunding because
it's an investment we have little more
stringent rules as to what we can and
cannot do
so I talk with sag and I said what's the
deal here because people are putting
money in to get a job because if you're
gonna in the movie that's a job if
you're one day two days whatever you're
shooting and and they said well it's
against union rules you can't pay to
play you can't pay to be in the movie
and you know we've to comply with the
universe I thought I gave it that makes
sense and it turns out it's also against
labor laws as well just even without the
Union so what we did instead was we
thought well we just love the idea of
having people that we don't know people
outside the business may were people in
again we just love the idea of putting
them in the movie so what we did instead
is we're running a contest free to enter
don't have to invest nothing just click
and you enter the contest and we're
giving away eleven parts in the movie
well are these bit parts or these fairly
substantial roles okay yeah they're big
parts they walk on rolls right speaking
line and we're shooting in LA in late
July early August we're not providing
transportation you got to get yourself
here okay but you get yourself here and
you win the contest you know
then put you in the movie you will be in
the movie be on the set with the stars
with the cast will direct you if you're
not a already an actor even right I will
direct you so that you'll fit right in
you know you'll have your dressing room
you'll get the makeup you get the star
treatment you know it'd be really fun to
do you know we love to welcome people
into the set and do that so yeah so
we're running a contest free to enter
just click click and you're in and you
get into once a day think
many entries as you want and then the in
July the computer will randomly pick
eleven of those people but we put you in
the movie so that's how we got around
the sag rule so we could get people in
we don't get any money from them but
it's fun yeah it's funny publicizes the
movie so it's like a random generator or
something yeah yeah I found out that
there are these sites these companies
that run these contests are they do
these random things there's a guy who
was doing an equity crowdfunding
campaign for the jetpack okay which is
amazing he did a contest and the winner
of the contest gets to be the first
civilian to fly with a jetpack
what a great prize right you get to live
in the future to be George Jetson per
day so yeah so other people have done it
and it's super fun since you're one of
the first feature-length films is that
right to do equity crowdfunding we're
the first feature-length narrative film
in the United States to do equity
crowdfunding yeah okay
and it sounds like you've done a lot of
research you and your team so if you
were to sit down and advise someone else
that wants to do the same what are some
top five things that they should be
aware of right away if you're allowed to
talk about that now I know there's sure
so within the guidelines of what you can
talk about yeah I can absolutely I can
talk about that
it's um that's a great question because
that's a question I would love to her
the answers to about six months ago when
I was embarking on this the first thing
you need to know is it's a ton of
paperwork it's like doing your taxes
times a hundred yeah there's a counting
paperwork legal paperwork you can hire
people to do this or you can do it
yourself okay but there are a few things
where you do have to have an actual
lawyer at least look it over because
it's an investment this is a serious
thing you know people are trusting you
with their money and you're saying hey
if you invest in our company we're going
to make money and we're gonna give you
more money back so you make a profit
that's what you're saying to these
people that's a serious thing you know
and people in show business we're
creative okay
we're creative people we like to tell
stories we like to write we like to act
we like to direct them
we're not accountants okay if we want to
be an accountant we'd be doing that you
know we're not lawyers or we'd be doing
that okay so you have to embrace the
fact number one that there's a lot of
paperwork and you're gonna be doing a
lot of jobs that are not fun and
creative like acting writing and
directing is okay so you have to embrace
that and do these chores you can hire
people to do it you can spend about ten
thousand dollars and have other
professionals do all that paperwork and
all that stuff for you or maybe like
five to ten depending on exactly how
much money you're raising the more money
you want to raise you can raise up to a
million dollars under the regulation
crowdfunding rules okay
you can hire people for five to ten
thousand dollars to do all that stuff
for you okay and then the second thing
is have a great video it's really
important Kickstarter campaign is that
you have to have a great video that gets
people excited okay the third thing
which I found out from I emailed people
who had done successful campaigns
people who had a biotech company an
electronics company food company
completely different from the movie
business but I emailed who said hi I'm
gonna do this you have any advice to my
surprise they wrote back generously told
me a lot of things and all these people
from these you know pretty uh you know
pretty different companies than us you
know they do biotech and things like
that
they said that the vast majority of
their investors invested for emotional
reasons for because they liked the
people they saw in the video who are
gonna be having their money and running
the company because they got a good
feeling for me he said 80 and a 90
percent of investors said that that's
why they invested then only about 10 or
20 percent or you know analytical
spreadsheet kind of people who drilled
down into all the numbers and everything
and invested for those recent asked
questions about you know your ROI and
you're this and you're that that was a
smaller percentage of people but
substantial they still put in a good
amount of money and so all these like
companies that were there
normal and strict and not like fun and
show business said it's emotional so I
thought wow because and it made sense to
me and I thought well I'm in show
business
if I can't make if I can't make a plea
that shows people how we feel about
doing this so that was the other big
thing you said five has three things you
want want five things oh so much
pressure so much pressure oh the other
thing is is you were it's gonna take
over your life it's this is 12 14 16
hour days online doing social media
spreading the word it's non-stop you
have to have at least two people on your
team full-time we hired a Facebook ad
team people who are doing the Facebook
ads and putting those out because we
didn't have time to do that
we hired consultants who has consulted
on other campaigns like ours to tell us
what to do so we could learn all this
stuff so you need a team of people
that's that's the other thing that's
four things with the five actually have
to follow ups yeah so then we can
actually almost make it seven okay but
so the follow-up is you said there's a
team of people that maybe you could pay
around five to ten thousand dollars to
do some of this paperwork and all that
what what's the name of that job
description like who what what type of
if we're searching for those companies
what are we looking for what's the name
of it oh well there's three things you
can you can search online for regulation
crowdfunding consultants and you can
find firms who do that there are some
who you can come to them and say I have
this product or a movie say I want to
raise the money and they say fine
you pay us X amount of dollars we'll do
all the paperwork so all you have to do
is provide us with some information sign
your name and we'll do all the ads with
you know and they cost more money okay
and they frequently will take a portion
of your company you know 5% 6% of your
company as part of their fee in addition
to you paying them upfront Oh
interesting so they're they become
business partner
with you yes their investors okay yeah
but you're paying them we're paying them
in money and you're paying them in stock
for your company you can find you can
find those companies around and you can
see what companies they've successfully
raise money for okay that's more turnkey
system or you can just hire an
accountant to CPA and an attorney who's
specializes in this field and again if
you search for ignition crowdfunding
attorney you will find people who
specialize in this
and I find it turn is a pretty good if
you have a kind of tourney and they
don't really know how to do this they'll
turn you on to somebody who does so you
can cut the money in half that you're
spending up front by just hiring them
for very specific tasks now what are
those tasks you need to do why does all
this paperwork the great resource for
that is the portal they call these
portals these are SEC registered
websites there's only 26 of them as of
this moment as a May 2017 and they have
to be registered with the SEC and you
have to run your campaign through them
through one of them they're like
Kickstarter but instead of Kickstarter
of rewards-based it's a investment based
okay you go to these portals and there
are the three top ones right now our
start engine which is what we're on we
funder and micro ventures those are the
top three right now yeah that they have
the track record you go to those sites
and they have a lot of great information
you know a fact that tells you what you
need to know if you want to raise money
this way okay so you can find that out
it's a lot of research because it's
unlike it's like three months just to
get to the point where you can launch
the campaign interesting three months of
solid work and then with hiring the
attorney
it sounds like are you just hiring them
for looking over the launching of the
campaign making sure the wording
everything is correct and again if I'm
overstepping my bounds with this okay so
so it's just sort of like you let them
know what needs to be done and then they
sort of give you their hourly rate and
then you're done once the campaign is
launched or they on retain
and you're following up with them
throughout the campaign it depends on
what you need them for
there are several firms that will do it
for a flat rate I say a few pay is
$5,000 we will do all the paperwork all
the legal paperwork to get you launched
and then a couple of follow-ups for
example when we had our press release
that we issued to the press to talk
about the movie I ran that by the
attorney to make sure that we didn't
violate any of the what they call
communication guidelines from the SEC to
make sure that we didn't say anything
for example you can't say if you invest
in our company you'll make a billion
dollars that's because that's a promise
that the SEC says gee you're not likely
to have that come true are you okay so
you can't you can't what for fo you
couldn't you can't lie to the public
that's just wrong anyway but you can't
over-promised in your excitement you
can't say this is gonna be the best
movie ever you know and so you can't
really say that according to the SEC you
can say hey this is our team we have an
Oscar we have four Emmys we know what
we're doing
and we're making this movie that you can
say because it's true it's a fact
so I ran all that stuff by the lawyer
and to make sure that we weren't being
over enthusiastic we were we were fine
so that's how you'd use a lawyer after
you've launched but all the other lawyer
work is getting ready for the launch and
the months before the launch because you
have to fill out a lot of things and we
by the way let's just campaign the SEC
does a background check on you I've
never had a background check done before
I felt so naughty but sadly I'm not that
interesting so I passed the background
check but yeah but everybody who does a
campaign on these portals who was doing
equity crowdfunding they've gone through
background checks to make sure that
right nothing
right no securities fraud or anything
like that right so then with the
Facebook ads anything you can recommend
because we've heard that for some people
they work very well and I'm wondering if
there's certain strategies with Facebook
Ads that you could recommend it if
that's within the guidelines
yeah the Facebook ads have done well for
us but it's been a real learning curve I
did not know about this whole world of
data that Facebook has I mean I've heard
about it read about it I use Facebook
but until I started purchasing ads when
you buy an ad Facebook you can say what
audience it is you can say age you can
say a male/female you can say they're
interested in this they're interested in
that and Facebook will tell you exactly
how many thousands or millions of people
fit the criteria and you can really
fine-tune the audience you can have your
ads run within a hundred miles of
Charlotte North Carolina only if you
want you can do amazing fine-tuning of
things and so it took a while for us to
fine-tune the people who would want to
invest in a Christmas movie and once you
reach them they're like oh that's great
but if you're somebody who you know only
likes horror movies they're they're not
interested so Facebook Ads can be very
effective and there are a million
consultants it would be happy to work
with you to help fine-tune these ads and
they'll run like 20 different ads that
are like subtly different or really
different and then they measure exactly
how well it does so then they can you
can just narrow it down and find out you
know I think of it as when you when you
go you know a sitcom when you're
shooting a live sitcom with a live
audience
you do the scene and you see how the
audience reacts and if they didn't laugh
enough in certain places the writers
quickly write new jokes so they have
other jokes already and they give them
to the actors they do the scene again
and change two or three or four or five
of the jokes in the scene and see if the
audience laughs better so it's a similar
process to doing Facebook Ads you
fine-tune it till it resonates with the
audience just like you know making that
live audience laugh now did you work
with a consultant or you
done all this on your own with your team
in terms of purchasing the ads looking
at the metrics and things like that I
did it all myself for the first couple
of weeks because I thought it was
interesting and then I realized that I
learned enough to know what I don't know
so I handed it off to people who do know
who live and breathe this sort of thing
so they can get results more quickly you
know it's like I mean hey you could you
could you know you could run the camera
and the sound and direct and write the
whole movie but don't you hand off that
camera and that sound you know somebody
who does that for a living so okay so
you knew what your strengths were and
you knew when because they say
successful people always ask for help so
it sounds like that's good you don't
have to do everything yourself
yeah but I'm glad I did do it for a
couple of weeks because now I understand
what the heck they're talking about
that's when they talk about you have to
learn things like click-through rates
cost per click every time somebody
clicks on your ad and Facebook you pay
Facebook so I just learned all this
amazing stuff very cool yeah it's good
that you know what you're you know
getting into but in terms of having
someone else fine-tune it it sounds like
you wanted them to do it yeah
now with this campaign is this an
all-or-nothing campaign no we've reached
our minimum so once you reached a
minimum you know you're good to go
we've reached actually 700 percent of
our minimum oh wow yeah in seven weeks
so it's well we'll have a link below
this video and on the site so people can
go to it and they can see more what
you're talking about so we don't
overstuff anything so
for those watching the video they can go
to your campaign and we'll have a link
to it and they'll see that you've done
incredibly well how much do you think
luck plays into it and how much of it is
the team that you have and the hard work
well I will always take any luck that's
coming my way but it's like the old
saying the harder you work the luckier
you gets and where the luck comes and I
think is if you hit the zeitgeist
if you hit a feeling that people have
now where this movie that we're making
resonates with them you know is it the
right time for this
I mean sometimes you'll see a movie and
it'll be years ahead of its time and it
doesn't do well and then like years and
years later it does like crazy good on
DVD and download and cable because now
it's the right time you know and then
you'll see some movies that come out and
they're just kind of dated and you've
seen them before and you like oh this
would have been great 20 years ago you
know oh gee your your movie about you
know somebody coming out of the closets
and having a gay marriage that that's
cutting edge 30 years ago you know so it
has to be really really good if it's not
like super fresh
so the luck has to do with timing are
you hitting the mood of enough people in
the country so that they like your idea
but I tell you one thing we do feel is
grateful
anytime somebody puts in small
investment big in and whatever it is we
feel really grateful and and obligated
to make the best use of their investment
that we can we have a philosophy and I
talk about this on the investment page
our philosophy is put it up on the
screen when money goes into a movie and
you have a budget that budget is
allocated to different things or hiring
the crew your paying actors you're
renting locations you do all these
things that need to be done you're
purchasing insurance you're paying for
the lawyer to get all this stuff
together all these things that need to
be paid for we want to put it all up on
the screen if we rent when we go into
production you were in production
offices that you're going to need for
two months now if you're in swanky
offices in Beverly Hills
that money is not gonna be seen on the
screen okay just rent some cheap stuff
in North Hollywood that's perfectly fine
got some parking yeah okay you've got
offices and the money you saved will go
on the screen and form of getting more
days to shoot that money can another two
three four days of shooting there or
paying for an expensive actor to guest
star in it or or getting bigger sets
more production value put it on the
screen so going back to what you said
about you know the harder I work the
luckier I get
that's a great quote um I forgot who
said that but it's I see a lot in like
these business quotes and things like
that can you tell me anything from your
interesting life and I know you've been
in different realms from comedy magic
television writing where you felt luck
really was a part of it and that you're
very grateful for that any interesting
story where you just kind of fell into
the right place the right time well like
I said I was on the road doing stand-up
comedy and it's can be very very
difficult
which sounds sounds oh poor you you get
to travel around and tell the jokes oh
my heart bleeds for you what's your
GoFundMe campaign and I would watch
comedians on talk shows talk about home
of the road it's really hard and I would
just go what do you boo you have a great
life but then when you do it I performed
in 48 states Canada England all over the
place and after a while it's just it's
really draining I can't have a
relationship you get it's just it's very
destabilizing so I really need to go
through it emotionally I had to get off
the road I went to go see a sitcom
because a friend of mine was guest
starring on the show so I went she goes
want to come watch I go sure so I go sit
in the audience never been to one before
didn't know the show the show was funny
she was good in it and there was this
guy doing audience warm-up which is the
job they hire a comedian to talk because
it takes two three four five hours to do
the show and they talk in between the
scenes and they're talking they're with
the audience a lot and this guy was
terrible he was awful he was just
annoying and no you liked him and I felt
bad for him as a performer but also as a
performer I felt bad for him my heart
went out to him as an audience member I
was just
annoyed and I thought hmm they're paying
him to do this I thought hmm so after
this it's just show ended said to my
friend backstage I said hey introduce me
to the producer she was okay so I meet
the producer said hi I'm David Willis
I'm a comedian is that your normal
person who does the audience warmup and
she rolled her eyes the producer rolled
her eyes and goes no and I go look if
you try him you have no excuse not to
try me I can't be worse right she left I
gave her my tape she said okay we'll try
you and so it was lucky that my friend
was on the show and that and that they
had a bad warm-up and that I was there
at the right place at the time so that I
got that gig I got to get off the road
okay and do audience warm-up for a few
years and that was my entree into that
whole world so yeah that's lucky I'll
take it I'll take the luck just off
camera you told us that you go to meetup
groups for writers and I'm just
wondering what meetup groups strike your
eye in terms of why you go to it and and
what do you get out of going to well
when I was first starting writing I had
some people help and give me some advice
the first writers group that I went to
that I was a part of it was all sitcom
comedy writing and the very first notes
I ever got my first TV script was this
was so boring I was falling asleep and
we all laughed and because comedy
writers can be can be pretty vicious in
a funny way and and then he said when
you got to this part that's when I woke
up and it was really funny
so this group showed me that right away
that you need honest feedback okay but
constructive Christmas because he this
is this particular he gave me that note
but then he told me what was working so
I go you know what you're right I feel
the same thing I agree with the note and
so it really helped me out that group
that little writer's group I was in
eventually dissolved because everyone
got work
that's a great reason for a group to
dissolve right everybody was working on
these shows so so I thought you know was
really helpful when I was first starting
out so I thought I'd like to help people
too so I go to the meetup site and I see
those writers group so I go to some of
these and I just give them notes you
know gentle nose encouraging notes been
honest notes and you know it's a it's
helpful to people and if you don't ever
give something back or help out other
people it that doesn't feel very good
so okay that's your way of giving back
what do you see and I won't ask you five
things but what do you see as several
top things that most of most writers new
writers have trouble with well the two
big things are one is a passive lead
character I see that quite a bit see it
over and over their lead character has a
bunch of people coming at them and doing
things you know saying oh you should do
this and he goes okay and he does it
it's got if it doesn't come from within
the character then you've got no train
you got no choo-choo pulling the Train
it's not pulling the story train what
you got is a caboose pushing it that
doesn't work okay you need to pull it in
going somewhere and I see that a lot
just with this passive lead characters
and the other thing is either no
conflict or very lower case conflict
where people are safe it's TV people are
flipping through channels and they watch
something for five six seconds if there
isn't deep conflict that's popping off
the screen they kind of keep flipping
they're flipping past your show okay so
you like conflict you know when you
watch TV you like it put it in your
script
one of the reasons is difficult is
because in real life people don't like
conflict if you're a nice person
okay you don't want to yell and argue
with people and you don't want to hurt
people's feelings okay but in real life
that's great in a script that's boring
it's just really boring
so let the conflict go okay let it go
into that script put it in there and
then it will jump off the page when
people read it kind of have a passive
lead character and not enough conflict I
see those two things all the time and
the other thing that I see is people are
safe I have a professional comedy
writers group and people apply to it and
we've had like a thousand people apply
in this group and there's only 20 people
in it so it's you know we always just
like certain people to be in it it's a
most of whom are professional or their
show runners and they write for them
shows oh and if they're newer writers
they're good and they're on their way
and I get people applying to the group
you know perfectly nice people we're
people who send their script and they
have screenwriting degrees
you know sometimes multiple degrees and
in writing in theatre and everything in
their script happens at exactly the
right time the inciting incident the
first act break the midpoint the third
act and all these story threads are
perfectly correct and I don't give a
crap because they were so busy being
correct in their form they haven't put
any spark of madness into the script
then put anything quirky and personal
you know and it's not in there it's like
forget all this stuff you learn and just
let it pour out just allow your
craziness your weirdness your quirkiness
to be poured into that script that's the
other mistake I see is people they're
holding back we want this is show
business
okay this is the one business where
there's nothing wrong okay you can let
these characters say weird things crazy
things politically incorrect things mean
things stupid things anything you have
the license to do an infinite number of
things do it okay so speaking of
conflict let's say the conflict was not
in the script but when you gave a note
was there ever conflict and was there
ever a time
where you thought there would be and you
work scared and actually the person
thank you yeah that's happened I mean
there's there's a way to give a note
your job when you give notes is to help
the writer tell the story they're trying
to tell help them tell it better you say
hey this character is coming off as this
is that what is that what you meant and
they're like oh no no no I meant to be
there they go oh well it's coming off
because of this and you tell them and
they they're grateful like oh I didn't
realize that you know excuse me from
little things like I was giving hosted
one person and he described he's
described a character as elderly this
elderly character and then in the next
paragraph he called him 50 years old yet
see you're laughing and a lot of people
at the table were you know around 50
host so I said you know what do you say
elderly we're thinking you know and
you'd say 50 right and he goes what
isn't he's a very young writer he says
wasn't that person that elderly and like
all the people were like no you know and
I said the reason this matters is
because hey it's a little confusing you
we just want you want clarity in the
script and be if somebody who's reading
this you know who could hire you is 50
and you call them elderly it's just why
create trouble right so there's little
notes like that and but I was working on
a show I came to work one day and there
was a writer who was walking out with
their stuff in a box and they had just
been let go and it was like ooh and we
didn't ask the executive producer
anything we didn't you know but but he
said it's really nice guy this week but
he said she didn't know when to stop
defending a pitch in the room she was
perfectly nice woman and everybody liked
her but when you're in the writers room
in a sitcom there's a bunch of writers
there and you'll pitch an idea the
executor said oh we need this in this
scene and you'll pitch an idea and
exec producer will say oh yeah that's
great listen to write that or they'll
say he'll say oh that's almost not quite
other people will pitch in and put
something pitch and like three or four
pitches later based on your pitch you
come up with a solution in the script
and you write you write it or executor
will say no you should move on okay
because it's their job to know what's in
the show the exec producer it says that
and you don't wanna have discussions
about it
and she kept defending she goes away she
kept coming back to him goes well you
know if you did the thing I say and it's
like well it's it just wastes time and
it puts makes the executor feel bad
because they've got to keep saying no so
he eventually just let her go so I
learned from that that was in my career
when you're given a note like know by
your boss
okay take the note you know also
sometimes there's what's called out if
you've heard the concept the note behind
the note yeah and sometimes there's
something under the note that is not
clear so you have to clarify the note
for some money you know but it's your
job if you're gonna be notes some
professionals rates your job to explain
the note until you see the light go on
in their eyes
okay that's your job to make them
understand the know you know and maybe
your note is a great note but it's not
the right note for the story they're
trying to do but when I'm working at
these meetups with newer writers and
stuff like that you take into account
that they're new you know and I've seen
a million scripts and I've solved a lot
of script problems and they haven't seen
those yet you know so you're just trying
to say hey this problem in your script
has been solved in a couple of ways by
doing this in this and how does that
feel and when you're giving the note you
can't be attached to the note if it's
not if it's not a professional stage
where if you're not their boss or
whatever you can't be attached to it you
can't get upset if they don't take your
note I mean it's not about you okay so
about the writer and their script so
there's some really fun writers at these
meetup groups there's a very talented
people of all ages you know and it's
great that they can come together and
and see their their stuff come to life
it's great that the over fifty ones
actually can
get out of the house like this I'm so
glad they can make it there yeah but
I've written it I can't get up
how many talented ones truly great
writers would you say have MFA's even
have a bachelors versus those that maybe
don't do you think it's really necessary
um gosh I don't know excuse me I know
someone who just got a masters and
television writing from Loyola and but I
don't really know everyone's resumes I
think in these groups and what they were
into the nice thing about I've noticed
about people who go to college and they
get the screenwriting degrees is when
you're young you just don't have that
much to write about yeah it's because
you haven't it's like a lot of comedians
don't get successful till they're at
least like 30 because they just haven't
done that much yet you just need time on
the planet and as a writer the more time
you have on the planet you know the more
you have to draw from so that's the
great thing about going to college is
that while you're young is to learning
you can learn the craft and the
technique so that when you do have more
things to write about you have the
technique you gotta get better first
yeah probably 35 is writers yeah writers
are frequently there's a bit even when
they're successful there's a bitterness
writers when writers get together they
just love to complain if you're if you
don't have an agent you love to complain
about you don't have an agent when you
do have an agent you complain that
they're not sending out your stuff
enough okay when you sell a pilot you
complain because the pilot didn't get
made when you get a pilot made you
complain because it didn't go to series
when you have a series you complain that
it only ran two years instead of six
years okay and I guess if you're Chuck
Lorre you complain that you only have
three series on the air instead of six
I mean writers will always find a reason
to complain we're creative that way but
they voice what most people are already
thinking you know maybe they just don't
want to say it so those that are
embittered enough to say it
yes we won't say that but we want to we
want to hear it well that's a writer's
job is to voice things that people can't
say so you're doing research on sort of
a holiday-themed film or maybe it's just
because you also like holidays themed
films I mean talked about a Christmas
story things like that what makes a good
either
Christmas film or Halle even Halloween
something that's a theme that they know
every year it's going to come up people
are gonna want to watch it they're gonna
want to watch it in a certain
environment they're gonna be in a
certain place in their lives whether on
vacation or having time off from work
well when I decided to write a Christmas
movie for this low-budget Christmas
movie I looked at my favorite Christmas
trees that I liked elf a Christmas story
even Bad Santa and it moves like that
and I analyzed them I mean you know it's
my business my job so I analyzed them
and I see what do they have in common
what makes it a Christmas movie and why
do I like it and I discovered some
things in common with the good Christmas
movies first of all Christmas has to be
in jeopardy Christmas must be in danger
in elf literally Santa can't fly his
sleigh until people believe in Christmas
again yay in a Christmas story if he
doesn't get that BB gun okay his
Christmas will be ruined or high all the
great Christmas movies Christmas is in
jeopardy and the other thing is it has
to be family has to be about family
Christmas is about reaffirming the
family unit in National imprudence of
Christmas vacation okay his relatives
visit in the form of Randy Quaid who's
obnoxious he Chevy Chase can't stand him
okay
he's not getting Chevy Chase doesn't get
the Christmas bonus that he'd thought he
deserves and that he needs you know to
keep his family together and so there's
all this dangerous stuff his relatives
are ruining Christmas his boss is
ruining Christmas and all he wants to do
have a great Christmas okay so that's in
danger too and it's the family that
provides the solution when he finds out
that he's not getting the Christmas
bonus for his boss his crazy brother
Randy Quaid kidnaps the boss and brings
him there so that Chevy Chase can tell
him off okay which is a stupid thing to
do to kidnap your boss but the boss has
an epiphany you know and it says and
then comes through and gives us and
gives the bonus so his crazy stupid
weird family that Chevy just hated has
provided the means to save Christmas
okay so that's another element that's in
that one in elf okay the piece of there
to literally find his family he finds
his father who James Caan who doesn't
believe in Christmas okay but by the end
of the movie James Caan has reaffirmed
that he is indeed his son that Will
Ferrell is his son and now he believes
in Christmas so it's in every single
good Christmas movie Christmas is in
danger it involves the family and
together they save Christmas and weirdly
enough I mean if you have are enough of
a writer geeky audience they'd
appreciate this but in every Christmas
movie - almost all of them there's a
subtle and and brief sexual element
which sounds crazy but think about it
and it's a wonderful life there's this
fallen woman which in the parlance of
the time men you know a trample this way
and she's gonna leave town so there's
that brief thing about that it's like
why are they put why did they put this
in here in a Christmas story there's the
leg lamp okay which was very sexual it's
a damned leg this big you know and like
with that black stocking on it and the
wife is like uh what's that doing here
she's threatened sexually in the Chevy
Chase movie a Christmas vacation he's
looking at the neighbor over the fist
the woman who's swimming in the bikini
and there's a slow-motion shot and she's
swimming and the waters dripping off of
her and is this doing what is the
the fantasy doing in a Christmas movie
in elf
she's taking his zooey deschanel is
taking a shower where she's in the
shower
she's naked in the shower we don't see
it but we can tell and she's singing and
Buddy the elf is listening and he's in
there he's not looking but he's
listening so that also is like a sexual
romantic element what are these little
things doing in these Christmas movies
when I was analyzing I thought why are
these here why do they work and then it
hit me it's there because Christmas
itself the holiday season has kind of
nobility about it as sort of a higher
purpose people are and people are being
their best selves they're giving they're
buying things for people they're getting
together by the fire they're snuggling
up there's all these really wonderful
positive knowable things that are people
doing these higher things
okay and when they bring in this sexual
element no matter how silly it is if
it's in the shower if it's the leg it's
earthy that is a little touch of
earthiness you know of something based
something a little core something very
primal down here where's the other thing
hits you in the heart this hits you in
the gut you know and and it's just there
I decided it's just there to provide
contrast to the nobility of the rest of
the movie okay and it's gives the
sentimentality of a bigger impact in the
end and I thought about I thought you
know what if they didn't have little
coarse elements in there the film would
be treacle you know it would stick to
the bottom of your shoe it would just be
too sickly sweet and by doing that you
have the perspective by diverting a
little bit into the earthly area you
then give yourself the viewer gives
themselves permission to enjoy the
sentimentality and the sweetness at the
end that's my theory anyway what makes a
story boring what makes a story boring
yeah anything with superheroes sorry hey
I don't like superhero movies why I mean
it you know I've watched I sat down and
watched like a dozen
once because I said okay wait I gotta
look at these I'm not giving a fair shot
I just you know there's a guy run around
in tights if you're running around in
tights you should either be sword
fighting you know in the sixteenth
century or in a ballet ballet is great
but the I just I just never buy into it
but I you know they're fun I get people
like them but I figured out why they're
popular even though I'm not the audience
it's because it's replacing religion the
single largest religious demographic in
the United States under the age of 30
are the non-religious and so religion is
having less importance in life in
America today and I think it's being
replaced with the mythology of the
superheroes because you get to see you
know like the ancient Roman gods the
ancient Greek gods they had old Pantheon
always it and now that's taking the
place you know and company and you can
dress up like them and you can go to
comic-con and you can engage in your
religion all right that's my theory
that's my crazy writer theory no good so
then a non superhero movie what makes a
non one boring take that out of the
equation what makes a movie boring story
in general I know you talked early about
not enough conflict or passive
characters I think a story is boring if
it doesn't matter if there are no stakes
if the people in the movie if they don't
care a lot about what is happening and
what they're doing then the audience
won't care that's to me what makes the
story boring if you're watching a
character and they need to Rea they need
$10,000 why do they need $10,000 are
they paying for their child's operation
to save their life that's important I'd
be like oh that matters okay are they
just trying to buy a car so they can go
to work or like okay that's a real thing
I guess but
oh so what you know oh you know James
Bond is is you know it's he does he have
to kill this guy because you know
because the guy took his parking space
or is he doing it to save the world you
know why you know unless you the frame
the French can make movies about being
boring to make those work you know there
are certain indie films where you can
you can actually delve into that and in
a deeper way but for me that's it if the
stakes aren't there if it if the story
if the hero succeeds or doesn't succeed
or whatever why does it matter it
doesn't matter I don't care so for you
when you go to see a film and I know you
said lately that you've been so busy
with all this you don't even have time
to watch television but before all that
could you tell within the first few
minutes I was going to be boring oh
absolutely absolutely my girlfriend
bless her heart just has to listen to me
you know after the first minutes of
immunity I'll say this is what this
movie is about just because I can't
can't help it but like we recently saw
their finest you know their finest is a
British film about a woman who is hired
to make propaganda films in World War
two in England and in the first few
minutes of that movie they bring you to
London world war two under the Blitz
you know there's bombs coming down and
there's this young woman who needs a job
and because her husband in some of the
hard time getting hired and so she needs
a job and she goes into the office of
the propaganda that the probably ganda
film office with the British government
they they call her in and the stakes are
there for two reasons if she doesn't get
a job okay her and her husband or she
knows were in trouble
and if she doesn't make good propaganda
films then the public you know that is
being bombed okay
may feel more bleak whereas if she does
a good job with these films they'll feel
better
no we all know how World War two ends so
that's it's not like if that's in doubt
and we're wondering Gigi who wins here
you know but it's super but we don't
know how individual people felt in
London at the time being bombed so
that's a mystery we're gonna find that
out so immediately the first five six
minutes of the film you care if she gets
this job and if she's good at it what
was it about those stakes because I mean
the storyline sounds great but if
someone else did it and the stakes
weren't there there must have been
little nuances about how they drew you
in that that made you sit up on the edge
of your seat a little more well they had
several kinds of stakes they had just
personal the war they had the big stakes
the the broad stakes the morale of
London the morale of England during this
fight those were the big stakes then
they had the personal stakes she was a
woman they brought her in it was this
this film office was run all by all men
okay and they were very dismissive of
her they had been told by a higher-up
that the propaganda films that they were
making that the female dialogue was
terrible and so they said you know well
let's bring in this girl and she'll
write the female bits and they'd bring
her in they're very dismissive you know
you do all the rest of the work my dear
you just just fill in the female bits
yeah and it was very dismissive
so right away there's this chauvinism
appropriate for the time and and you're
like hey that's not right you know 2017
you're like yeah you know and so there's
these immediate personal stakes as well
so they added a layer to it that that
was stranded throughout the movie but it
wasn't all about just a girl-power they
moved beyond that later in the movie
they made it even deeper sure but that
that those different layers it sounds
like drew you in there were the higher
stakes than her her stakes at home and
then you add this sort of like combative
environment that she has to go into so
there was many things interesting right
okay so then when you see a movie that
within the first five minutes it falls
flat are we only seeing one layer
is that sometimes why orgy it sounds
like we really can't break it down to a
science but yeah it's not a sign if it
was a science then you know we have
computers do it we just uh nobody knows
what's gonna be hitting what isn't and
there's so many factors in making a
movie so many factors from the script to
what the director is doing with and the
cast you know oh one a cast member one
actor may make a character sympathetic
the other another different actor might
make them annoying you know it's just so
so many factors by the way I like the
name of your website film courage I'm
curious how you came up with that
because it takes courage to make a movie
even if you make a bad movie I mean
nobody says something a bad way if you
make a bad movie it still takes courage
I'm not talking about the fake kind of
courage that like Apple has when they
take away our headphone jack on the
iPhone but it does take courage and to
make a good movie takes even more
courage you have to take a chance you
have to go out on a limb you have to do
something that hasn't been tried before
because if we've seen it all before
why do we want to see it again why why
does they take courage because it seems
like if it's in you and you just pours
out wouldn't wouldn't nothing stop you
or is it putting it out in the public
space and holding it up to the light for
scrutiny that's where the courage comes
in to well that definitely but to do it
in the first place I mean to go into
show business in the first place on the
face of it's a stupid idea
300 people move to Los Angeles every day
to become actors okay that is a million
people over ten years who've come here
just to be actors now the odds usually
look at the numbers the odds of you
becoming successful as an actor are
terrible as a writer
they're terrible okay so if you look at
it logically you go well am I gonna do
that I'm gonna become a doctor I do
something else because it's there's a
there's a very clear path I get my
degree I go to medical school
become a doctor it's clear it's logical
it's reasonable so to even go into show
business takes courage because the odds
are you're going to fail so the people
who make it are the ones who can't do
anything else
and by that I mean they won't get out of
bed for anything else they just can't
they have to do it they're driven to do
it those are the ones who don't give up
who keep going because they can't do
anything else they just keep doing it
what about the theory that you know they
say most entrepreneurs that are
successful it's it's they didn't really
want to look at some of the odds and
they were you know you know the infamous
Steve Jobs speech you know the crazy
ones the ones that kind of you the one
the ones that sort of don't see it they
don't want to see it you think that also
plays a part not just that they can't do
anything else but that they I don't want
to say naively believe because it's not
naive but that they can't see that they
won't succeed I'm not explaining it
right forgive me but but I don't
struggle okay yeah you've I've heard
really successful people talk about how
they didn't know that they couldn't do
something so they did it right or
sometimes smart people talk themselves
out of something right word yes yes it's
it's like I mean there's two sides to
that one is you willfully just ignore
bad odds you just say you know what it's
hard to make a movie it's hard to make
money from a movie it's hard to return
the investors money to give them a
profit okay so I'm not gonna do it or
you say hmm it's hard to return
investors money on a movie and be
successful I'm gonna look at the things
people did to see why they weren't
successful and I'm not gonna do that
I'm gonna do something to make it
successful
so there's like willfully just pushing
that stuff aside and making your own
damn path then of course there's the
other way where you're just sometimes
you're just to just you know in
ignorance there's bliss do you have a
routine when you're starting a
screenplay whether it's a feature-length
is short I often write backwards I often
think of an ending and then I think
what's a fun way to get there so I often
do that and then I think about it I
think about it a lot I just didn't let
it just let it boil around in there for
a while and then and then I outline it
right you know outlining getting the
story right that's the hardest part
you know once you've got all that down
which I got the story working in the
characters working then it's just easy
to to write it I have the stuff I've
sold everything with partners because
you know comedy is great to work with a
partner because you know you can you can
work off of each other you'll make a
suggestion they'll make a suggestion and
you play off each other's pitches and
then you arrive at something hopefully
that neither of you would have gotten to
a loan that's better so when you're
working with a in comedy with a writing
partner it speeds it up here like a
drafter too ahead of what you would have
been if you've been doing it alone what
are your best screenwriting habits and
then what are your worst screen already
habits and you don't have to give me
five by the way I could just hurt my
best screenwriting habits you know I
hate to say this but there's no there's
no like magic have it or thing you just
put your butt in the chair and you're
just right it's a job so whether you
feel like it or not you sit and you do
your job I mean there's no imagine I've
had some young writers say to me oh I'm
going on this writing retreat for a
weekend so I can finally work on my
script and like what I've never been on
a retreat to write I just just write
there's nothing magical about it
sure maybe the first draft will be you
know poopoo but if you don't write the
first draft you won't write the second
rap it's
it's a demystify other people just build
it up and do this a big magical thing
do you miss difficut just just do it my
words have in my own writing the last
thing I put in is visual comedy and set
pieces because that's not where my mind
goes first I have to remind myself make
this visual you know some of the
physical a big set piece where crazy big
stuff happens and that's just something
that it's the last thing I do because I
don't think about it first so that's
that's all I just have to remind myself
oh we could use something big gear and
then I and then I put it in and is that
your worst screenwriting how much for
Beth I mean that's your worst okay just
like that's that's like that's like a
weakness it's a weakness that I don't
that it's not like there from the start
I have to say you know it's like when
you leave the house and you go oh did I
leave the stove on I may have to be like
oh did I put in Oh No okay that's all I
mean there's nothing mysterious about it
you just just write just write your
script I mean you can't you can't teach
writing you're either a writer or you're
not you can teach technique you can
teach craft you can teach how to fix
certain problems but if you're a writer
you're writing every day and if you have
time they're right there today you're
you're thinking about it for the new
writers though don't you think they
almost need a ritual I know I know this
retreat idea for someone who has written
it sounds like why would you need all
that why would you need to fly there and
pay money whatever but maybe some people
need that ritual no just just you know
OMA in churches they had rituals
Christmastime is a ritual no the only
ritual is sit down and write that's the
only ritual there's okay there's nothing
else to it I it really isn't I mean I
wish there was some kind of magical and
people also ask me gee what book should
I read on screenwriting I'm just
starting right where I'm like don't read
a book no no don't read a book write
five or six scripts then read a book
because we read a book now it's abstract
it's theoretical you haven't
on it okay that's like saying you know
what sheet music should I buy
do you have an instrument no pick up an
instrument start playing it first okay
because the books will make no sense
I've read like five or six old scripts
before I ever read any books on
screenwriting and then I got a story by
Robert McKee and I'm like oh that's
interesting because I had a problem in a
script I couldn't figure out I solve it
and I was reading that and go oh that's
how I could fix it now if I'd read that
before I had the problem then that
particular chapter would have made no
sense to me
because I didn't have that problem yet
because I hadn't written enough I mean I
always say these new writers and like I
say well they're talking to me about
getting books and doing these things
like that I say how many scripts have
you written and if they answer me with a
number if they know how many scripts
I've written
how many scripts they've written they
haven't written enough scripts you
should know how many scripts you've
written you should be writing so many
scripts that you'd have to think about
it for a minute and figure out oh I
wrote this and that and if you know like
how many drafts exactly you did of
something you haven't done enough drafts
I mean wouldn't you do so much of this
you build the muscles you just keep
writing writing writing where you build
up the writing muscles and then you
don't need rituals you don't need this
stuff because you know you built it up
you can do it you said earlier about
writers under 30 that they really hadn't
lived life and I'm sure it would depend
on the individual yep I mean you know
there could be some people that have
lived by the time they're 15 and others
by the time they're 50 you know
everything's been safe and easy and
taken care of for them but what are some
things where they could live life let's
suppose they have just a normal life
with some good some bad
ups and downs how can they how can they
live life to sort of you know get a sort
of a writerly brain
that's a really bad we're getting toward
the end here I mean you know so they can
kind of have it be a little more well
rounded by 30 or whatever age doesn't
matter what age I guess
you just have to be around people you
have to have friends and you know
romances and things like that and you
get your heart broken and break some
hearts and you know just you know don't
don't sit at home watching you know
don't go to work for your day job come
on and watch TV for six hours and go to
bed go go to meetups go do stuff be with
people because that's what matters I
thought I was some weirdo who liked
doing this but I found out that other
people other writers like to do this
which is if you're in a cafe or whatever
eavesdrop on the people around you
because you are you're hearing real
dialogue and real stuff and it's really
illuminating you know so I don't know
it's the only advice I can offer is to
just get the heck out of you're out of
your apartment
get off your futon go live life have you
ever pitched to one of the studios yep
there's no one of the the indie Studios
when it's a particular script I mean I
pitched to them but this one particular
indie studio this producer I was brought
into meeting to pitch with him when I
was brought in by another producer who's
a woman and she's come meet this guy
will pitch him this movie so I came in I
pitched him the movie and it was a
romantic comedy and the male character
the lead character he starts out with
one girlfriend he breaks up with her he
ends up with another girlfriend by the
end of the movie and the reason I bring
that up is because to pitch it this guy
this executive he says so is this what
your life is like I said what do you
mean he goes well this guy he's got all
these women in your movie he's got all
these women what the hell is going on I
go well he has one girlfriend that he
gets another one I don't think that's
that's really a lot he goes I don't it
sounds like a lot to me that's like you
know so he seems like a womanizer that's
what he seems like I'm like okay I said
no whether it's this aggro was coming at
me but I'm like I would say it's just a
weird meeting anyway so we leave and the
woman producer that I came with she goes
I apologize I go what's going on she
because well I've been dating him and he
wants to be exclusive and I don't want
to be exclusive so so all this guy was
doing was sounding off at me as a way of
telling her you know you're you know why
won't you did why won't you be exclusive
to me you know that's really what the
minute was about you know so that was
the weirdest pitch meeting because it
had nothing to do with me you know and
sometimes it's out of your control what
can you do you just do your job
pitch pitch pitch smile do your job and
that's it
at least she was there to tell you that
because you wouldn't have known
otherwise yeah
you would have thought it was you yeah
and I was not dating her by the way but
at least someone was there because so
many times things like that happen and
there's an answer for it we'll never
know but at least you got to know that
so then when you went in to do other
things was that experience always up
there because you knew maybe it's
totally not about me but I don't have
that woman there telling me the story as
to why someone's acting this way yeah
one of the first pitches I did I came in
with actually a pretty famous writer
we've written something together and we
were pitching at Paramount and as we're
pitching he was talking he was he we had
this long super complicated really
detailed pitch that we thought was
wonderful he was describing it and as
that's we're pitching as we're telling
the story the guy this executive starts
to do this he starts to do anyway and
after a while we realized we're putting
him to sleep and you know we're comedy
writers so we stopped and he started
talking about it but it was like what a
note to get you're putting me to sleep
you know we actually literally this guy
and so that was like a huge lesson for
us we learned keep the pitch or don't go
into all these freaking details
so and never forget that one yeah well
there was no note behind the note knew
what was going on with that one okay
indeed